Oh what are you doing what is that it
hey everybody here we are once again and
sit here comment about Pookie yeah she's
funny
you walk around Pookie [ __ ] watches
you she said what you doing what what
what huh she's always like super
involved like even if it's something
that she's seen you do like a million
times
she's just like like what was that what
do you hope you yeah hit the Lights
which is she's like whoa clicking noise
yeah I was like asking because she was
just right out there and I was like well
she can't stick your butt in the camera
for old times sake she's really one
front door she's so crazy yeah yeah so
hopefully you guys enjoyed that very
long uh you know livestream that we did
last night yeah I was pretty [ __ ] up
too I really couldn't keep I really
couldn't keep track of what the topic
was
I don't even know it's like I'm kind of
like afraid to go back and listen to it
we probably only talked about the topic
for like I can't repeat yourself I
prepped
I don't remember repeating yeah but you
know I mean because I could have lists
and I was kind of going down there
through that for similar to one another
so I hope maybe that's what it was but
yeah it's it was people seem to enjoy it
though yeah well we do get kind of like
funnier they like the sloppier we get
problem cookie looking herself in the
mirror down there like oh is she really
well yeah we were just that was one
thing we I do remember we were talking
about lesson about animals identifying
themselves in mirrors oh she is looking
in the mirror we've like we had a mirror
like hanging up back there and now it's
like over there on the ground like at
pookie level and she's in there looking
at it going huh look at yeah I'm a
little bitty gray kidding jabberin bees
nest are in there saying it was a great
show last night
that's good like I said I remember
showing pictures and [ __ ] yeah girls it
was it was quite a while for her so yeah
unfortunately I was amazingly not
hungover this morning
really sure how that happened I think
because I took aspirin before I went to
sleep that's the secret but uh yeah we
just wanted to do kind of a brief
livestream today to do kind of like a
matinee because we haven't done one of
those in a while
today we're gonna be talking about a new
shutter or original horror movie and it
is called the beach house now in Qing Li
there is another movie that came out I
guess in 2018 or 2019 that is also
called the beach house or just beach
house which is like a romantic comedy
but that is not this one now this is
Addison listen to listen to what Mr Al
said yeah yeah all right you definitely
do need to be an extraordinary [ __ ]
group but yeah I want to do a live
stream tomorrow too because I just like
half an hour ago literally I just
finished watching season three of dark
and like I said I watched the whole
series like over the past week like 4 1
2 3 so I need to talk to somebody about
all of the [ __ ] that happened and well
although I'll probably watch like a few
videos prior to tomorrow like to see
because I don't know if I need it
explained explained but there were some
like threads that I'm not sure if they
were resolved and I have to go back and
like see where [ __ ] got picked up it's
gotta be explained to you I wouldn't
[ __ ] understand it I know it didn't
need to be explained to me like I got it
I was just like some of the the thing
about that show is that I feel like the
more I watch it cuz you need to watch it
a couple times like to make sure because
every single detail and every single
thing that somebody says is like comes
back into play later like nothing is
really like meaningless so that's kind
of all I'm saying there's just like
little details that I probably missed
out on because it's like a really
complicated like storyline and it was
just funny because it was already
confusing and cut and complicated like
in 1 & 2 and then 3 was like hold my
beer you know and I made it was kind of
like that type of thing they just like
which totally other why do but it was
like really really good and I really
like the way they resolved it so this
movie here this is action
a debut feature by somebody I think his
name is Jeffrey a brown so this is his
directorial debut as far as I can
determine this is kind of like um I
guess you'd call it's sort of quasi
environmental horror but also had a
little bit of a Lovecraftian kind of
vibe to it I thought did you find that
yeah yeah it's kind of like a you know
kind of like [ __ ] sea monsters from
the sea yeah or a light color at his
face because it was kind of light I mean
it wasn't like as wacky as that but it
was like a similar kind of thing we're
like something in the environment that
was maybe some kind of I don't know if
it was necessarily an alien microbe or
something like that but it or something
that came from the sea that had not been
identified or something and it was kind
of what we were going for so Dee was
bagging on color out of space of the day
what the movie yeah saying that that
Mandy worked the color out of space
didn't work I think it did I mean I
think they just [ __ ] on that director
because you know he had such a problem
on you know on her son on his last movie
on what was it island of dr. Moreau yeah
I think he got blacklisted from
Hollywood so yeah I don't even see that
movie so I mean I heard it was terrible
but I don't think it was just who you
have it's time yeah it was just a movie
whose time it had firuzan Balkan and B&Q
to [ __ ] as gay girl that's all matters
well okay and then it had just like
weird freaky people in costumes and
beasty oi human [ __ ] human animal
hybrid salt and orgies and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] headed uprising against dr.
Moreau that was kind of interesting
there was a movie of his time it wasn't
as mad as they said it was but that
original director who did color on his
face he didn't finish it he got kicked
off yeah they put somebody else on there
who evidently kind of [ __ ] it up even
worse I don't know that's just the story
you know Hollywood is men a bunch of
[ __ ] they're gonna talk [ __ ] about
each other
but some reason he kind of had like a
mental breakdown or something on the you
know yeah the production I think it was
just too much for him couldn't handle it
yeah you know that's what I heard and
then like you just kind of retired for
me but you know well I mean it's fair
enough if people didn't like
we're out of space for whatever reason
it's like I'm not one of those people
that's just like oh if he didn't like
this movie then there's something wrong
with you because everybody's opinions
are different I thought it was really
cool I thought ghoulia yeah I liked both
I liked Mandy probably a little bit
better yet I mean they're kind of two
different movies yes lists so it's like
hard to compare them right but um as far
as Lovecraftian movies go like I said
this one kind of had a little bit of
color out of space by baby or like a
Lovecraftian I don't know if I'd
necessarily call it Lovecraftian horror
because it's not quite as cosmic or
quite as over-the-top but it did have
like aspects of that so the the story of
it is there's like there's a couple
there's a couple they're like college
students I guess or like older college
students Emily and Randall now they go
to this beach house which I guess is on
the Hamptons did they even say I think
it's on the Hamptons somewhere but it's
like out but it's out of season it's
like um you know it's too early in the
season for anyone else to be in the
other beach houses so they decide to go
on this vacation at Randall's dad's
beach house now the dumb thing is that
Randall doesn't get along with his dad
so he neglected to tell his dad that him
and his girlfriend were gonna be staying
at the beach house so consequently when
they get to the beach house you know
they go upstairs they [ __ ] they do all
the stuff but then they find out that
another couple an older couple is
already staying in the beach house who
are friends of Randall's dad and have
been staying there for a little while
because like I said Randall was a
dumbass and didn't check say now hold on
for going further let's take it down to
the table low part of the draw the movie
is that the young couple who goes there
they're pretty much [ __ ] like eye
candy for [ __ ] the guys and the girls
the guys kind of like kind of like a
young version I don't know what's name
Jude Law kind of reminds it like a young
Jude Law or something I get I don't even
remember what he looked like um yeah and
the girls cute yeah girls cute so
they're kind of like the kind of like
that draw at a movie and they're also
kind of like the the main characters the
heroes yeah this is a very small cast
it's pretty much just these four people
and another one thing that I thought was
really well done about this movie is
that as I said because it's early in the
sea
and all these other beach houses along
this stretch of shore are empty so they
get when they go out to the beach
there's like nobody there so it's just
like this all this sand and this water
and it's just the way they shoot it like
like gives it a really cool feel of like
them being completely isolate even
though it's not like nighttime it's
daytime and everything but it still
looks like they're like these little
tiny people in this big kind of switch
like I said that is kind of what gave me
the Lovecraft vibe - yeah but so yeah so
there's a thing going on between like
the younger couple I guess I don't know
if they broke up at some point and then
got back together and this is supposed
to be like rekindling or something
because it does seem like at this point
in their relationship they're kind of
going in different directions because
she wants to go to grad school she's I
think organic chemistry or something
like that and he's dropped out of
college because I guess his parents are
rich and he's just like [ __ ] it he just
wants to lay around and do nothing so
they're kind of like at a crossroads and
then the older couple that are there
whose names are Mitch and Jayne I think
Jane is dying
I'm presumably of cancer I don't think
they say what it is so Mitch has kind of
brought her here like this is like the
last vacation like you know because she
might not like live till the next summer
and so he wants like her to have like
something he sent her off into the
[ __ ] force he jump makes it jump to
hyperspace tanning it well is it I think
so remember that Stella that's what the
[ __ ] that's what the the dude yelled
I guess that's what that was that was
from a different but we know it was the
original tenant before what roman
polanski moved in there yeah Stella
yeah I can't remember but yeah so what
ends up happening so the two couples oh
yeah I guess so the two couples decide
well they're gonna share the house cuz a
big house big house you know so they're
both gonna share the house so they kind
of bond even though there's like you
know but large age gap in between them
you know they're all sitting around
drinking and you know talking about life
and their future and everything then
they run out of booze and then Randall's
like hey guess what I got a whole bunch
of edibles so they all partake and then
[ __ ] starts to get weird
[Laughter]
chocolate we did it yeah so at one point
they all start seeing yep like weird
[ __ ] starts to happen like the
atmosphere starts getting very close
like this kind of fog rolls in
quote-unquote all the trees outside look
like they're glowing blue like I said
kind of like color out of space and so
and then there's like a weird smell and
then other things start to happen where
it looks like whatever this thing is
that's invading the beach house is an
organism of some kind or a whole bunch
of organisms and seems like it's taking
over people's bodies yeah it reminded me
a lot of color out of space I don't know
how much but you you're gonna want to
spoil though this is it well that's
pretty much as far as ours I'm not good
with it you know I will say I really
really did like this movie I thought I
mean it's not like you know mind-blowing
or anything but I really liked um you
know the way that the atmosphere that
they established like this kind of
isolation of this empty Beach is very
small cast they kind of did a good job I
guess you could call it a slow burn in
some ways but they did a good job like
building up the characters yeah it
wasn't like boring or anything like that
even though a lot of it like it took a
while like for the quote-unquote horror
to start I guess but they did a good job
building up the characters and the
relationships between the characters we
didn't know what it was what we were
getting into when we watched it I didn't
know if it was gonna be a ghost story or
what yeah if there was some creepy [ __ ]
that happened in the beginning before
you even deal with monsters and [ __ ]
yeah I was like what is this place
[ __ ] haunted or something you see but
it was good little flick was this a
Hollywood movie or an independent film
it was independent yeah and like I said
this was a directorial debut as far as I
know I liked it and you know so it does
it does have like a bunch of horror
elements later but it takes probably til
like the third act and then it gets like
more and it goes more in like a body or
like direction yeah or like a contagion
type of or um I don't like a damn what
you call environmental or yeah they
never do you just
it's never really explained what it is
yeah they will they leave a lot of
things ambiguous but I think that's good
because as I said sometimes you know
that puts you in the same boat as the
protagonist because they wouldn't
necessarily know it is what it was or
what it was going on they give hints and
things but they don't really have some
do it see yeah you don't know if it's
[ __ ] something about the thermal fits
on the bottom of the ocean or is it
alien or what is you know you don't
really know it could yeah it's like they
they very much leave it that it could
have been it could have just been some
unknown species that came from the
thermal vents it works should be an
alien species or something recently
there was another movie like this it was
kind of like a Scandinavian movie they
were all on a boat everybody fever see
yeah we review that one be reviewed it
this was a lot better than CPU yeah but
it was a similar theme not though where
you kind of got this these weird like
creatures like in the sea I like to I
mean I like to see fever but um I liked
this one a lot better I think just
because you know the the one location
the small cast I mean it's only four
people so you could you could kind of
like focus a lot more on those
characters and I think they did a good
job you know the the girl that played
Emily was like a really good actress and
they they were very wise I think to like
focus a lot on like her terror and like
which like what she was going through
and stuff so you really kind of like
related to what she was going through
and like how scared she was and all that
other stuff so I think they you know for
a very kind of small scale type of movie
I think they did a really good job with
you know like I said and we've said this
a million times before you don't need
like zillions of dollars to make a good
movie you don't even need like a super
original idea or anything it's all in
the execution you know what I'm saying
yeah and it's like if you have you know
good actors you have like good
cinematography you have like a good
build-up attention you have characters
that you care what happens to them and
kind of like an interesting story that
you want to keep watching then you don't
really need a whole lot of money or a
little lot of special effects or
anything like that
yeah it kind of it's kind of weird
because I like this one it was it was
this wasn't an expense
movie to make no I'm glad it was I'm
sure it'll make I'm sure it'll make
money I look at this and then there's
another movie that's kind of like it in
a way same kind of theme kind of
Lovecraftian was underwater yeah and I
loved underwater underwater got [ __ ] he
can't like [ __ ] crazy but people were
talking about what a [ __ ] that movie was
I [ __ ] liked underwater a lot I did
too it was like alien 1 or something and
then it was expensive it was an
expensive movie to make and I thought it
captured that alien 1 vibe and like
Prometheus and [ __ ] like that yeah and
it lost its ass which is just
unjustified I don't think I thought it
was great it's weird because it just
seems like you never know ever know what
I mean even because I've seen movies
that I thought were really good and it's
like that I thought people would like
and people wouldn't like I'm and
vice-versa like I've seen movies that I
thought were stupid that I thought oh no
one's gonna give a [ __ ] about seeing
that but then it made like a billion
dollars I think the reaso I think the
reason why they [ __ ] on that movie it
was the industry that was [ __ ] on
that movie they were [ __ ] on that
movie kind of like the way they were
[ __ ] on on on early to battle angel
I think it didn't give a political
message there was no politics in it and
I think that's why they shed on it I
don't I mean I had a female heroine that
was really good it had good special
effects had a good survival horror story
there's just nothing wrong with that
movie it looked great I bought into it
well then they come out and [ __ ] talk
about what a piece of [ __ ] it is and I
was like well word it's almost like
player hate well the thing about it
though I mean I read some reviews of it
I mean the reviews out of it that I read
were not terribly negative it's like
really the worst criticism that I saw of
it was that it so it was kind of like
that it was too much like alien or it
was kind of like a ripoff or something
that was kind of the worst one that I
saw of it and I think the thing about it
too I mean I don't know why cuz I don't
know if it was so much a critical thing
is like people just didn't really want
to go see it for whatever reason I don't
know if it was something to do with
Kristen Stewart because she still has
that stink of Twilight about her even
though she's been in a ton of other
things since then so I'm not really sure
I thought she was great she was good but
like I said she still has that
I mean I guess maybe I discuss nowadays
well you have you have all these
Hollywood directors and all these
studios so I can sell in all these
female centric movies with female leads
and [ __ ] and they'll talk about the ones
that are kind of mediocre they'll talk
about how great they are but then the
real good ones they'll say how shitty
they are like a late I had a had a
female main character they talked with
all they did just talk [ __ ] about that
movie they hated that movie well like
any sense
well I don't that's the thing it's like
I you know I don't read tons of reviews
I mean unless we're gonna review it then
sometimes but a lot of times I don't
like most of most of the worst reviews I
read of it or just kind of like med
they're not like it's not the reviews
that I'm talking about I'm talking about
people that are [ __ ] in charge
Studios and other directors and people
that were you know would he call them a
journalists in the [ __ ] movie
industry you know like Scott Mendelsohn
and [ __ ] like that [ __ ] from
newspapers they're the ones that talk
[ __ ] about those movies and it's just
doesn't make sense they pick and choose
ya not I mean what female movie they
like it's just crazy well and like I
said - you can't really I don't know I
don't know if there's any kind of like
background anything because some people
are just gonna like some movies and not
other ones it's like sometimes I've seen
movies that all the critics really
really liked and I saw it and I just
thought it was mediocre and vice versa
like sometimes there's like a movie that
a lot of critics hated then I saw it and
I really liked it someone is asking have
we seen Dog Soldiers yes we have and
actually we did a review of it as well
a while back pretty good yeah wet
stranger moving easily one of the best
werewolf movies we should probably do
ginger snaps one of these days because
that's a really good werewolf movie as
well and I feel like there's not make a
whole hell of a lot of werewolf movies
you know there's there some that are
good but yeah and even I think Ginger
Snaps even the I remember the sequel
being pretty good - all that's been a
while since I've seen it those two might
that might be on shudder or to be I know
I've seen it somewhere the other day but
um yeah so this movie I don't know it's
probably like available other places too
but it just went up on shutter yesterday
or the day before or Friday when I
I know because we just watched it the
other day this is their newest one
shutter original I think it originally
came out of festivals like last year but
I think as far as I know this is like
the first time that it's going VOD so if
you kind of like sort of low-key but
quasi Lovecraftian type of horror like
environmental horror a little bit of
body horror you would probably dig this
yeah what an expensive either I think
there's five bucks for to rent no we saw
it on shudder oh it was on shudder
that's right yeah we saw it on cheddar
um and like I said tomorrow we'll
probably do another livestream probably
I don't know I'll probably do it about
three o'clock to talk about dark so and
like I said I'm gonna spoil all of it so
if you guys want to talk about it you
know with view to knowing what the end
is and if you have any theories then get
him ready because I want to talk about
that show with you guys I'm gonna do
like some deep dive and like later on
like figure out some [ __ ] that I uh that
I couldn't figure out but yeah so you
are you done you have my chalk and I
write more to say about yeah cuz I mean
we did kind of do a live stream last
night and I'm stoked
we'll see you guys tomorrow I gotta say
and I kind of want some more of that
Indian food we actually went and got
takeout the senator noon we hadn't got
any for a long time our Indian
restaurant the around here that we love
is still open happily yep
you just have to go and pick up
everything all right so we'll see you
guys again tomorrow and thanks for
dropping by as usual